today we're going to take a look at the
song and video that has
caused the stir in recent days this is
montero by
lil nas x you may remember lil nos x
he's the guy who made
old town road which is a quote-unquote
country song
that sounds a lot like the rough draft
of a real country
song that somebody wrote in 92 seconds
on the back of a paper plate when they
were sleep deprived and drunk
what i'm trying to say is that the song
sucks and has always sucked and i tried
to warn people about this when it first
came out but
you all wouldn't listen to me so you
made lil nas x
rich and famous as a musician despite
his near total lack of musical talent
despite the fact that he clearly has
nothing at all to say or offer
whatsoever now here is the consequence
you did this to yourself
let's um we're not we're not going to
watch this i don't think we can make it
through this whole thing but we're going
to watch as much as we can
this is little nas x montero let's check
it out
i called it badges today you hit me with
a car to your place
ain't been out in the wall anyway was
hoping i could catch you throwing smiles
in my face
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay a couple of thoughts here uh first
of all artistically speaking
the song is trash a lot of very
expensive visuals
went into this video but underneath the
glossy packaging is a song that sounds
entirely indistinguishable from
about 50 000 other songs if you heard
just the melody and some of the lyrics
you you would have
no idea who made the song because it
could have been made by any of about 600
different pop artists
this is the musical equivalent of canned
food you just pull it off the shelf pop
it open
here you know and here's another song
sounds just like this served right up
ah but but hang on hang on you say see
this is different
this is totally unique because whereas
normally
these songs are vulgar and sexual this
one is
more vulgar and more sexual you see what
he did there
he was a true pioneer this guy he
listened to pop to modern pop music
and he thought to himself hmm what if i
did exactly that
but made it slightly dumber and cruder a
true moment of artistic inspiration i
mean this kind of moment
kind of moment that michelangelo must
have had when he conceived of the
the sistine chapel and it was this
inspiration that led to lyrics like
and i quote i want to sell what you're
buying
i want to feel on your in hawaii
the man is a poet you can't deny that
and by poet i mean that he has the
writing talent of a sixth grader
scribbling curse words in the back of
his math textbook
okay now we're gonna we're gonna skip
ahead a little bit because i can't watch
this whole damn thing
i can feel my brain shedding brain cells
in protest as we watch this so we're
gonna skip ahead a little bit uh until
we get to uh
this part right here watch
[Music]
call me
[Music]
how do i care if you're lying
[Music]
um you know i i just i was watching the
video i
kept thinking about uh this article that
i just saw
online as scientists announced that um
there's that there's not going to be any
asteroids to threaten the earth for the
next 100 years
there's not gonna be any we don't worry
about any earth destroying asteroids for
at least the next 100 years
and um i watch a video like that and i
think well that is such a disappointment
you know that that's that's devastating
news because that was our way out
it's a damn asteroid now the first point
to make about
this satanic imagery that you just saw
there is
that this dude is trying desperately to
shock and offend us
with the same routine that was wasn't
even all that shocking when marilyn
manson did it
two and a half decades ago this is not
interesting it's not bold
it your kids today if you're a kid and
you see that you're like oh no one's
done it no this has been
like they've been doing this for decades
this shtick
it's been done a million times i mean i
i've seen cards
in cards against humanity that are more
surprising and shocking than this
and this really is it is this looks like
they wrote a bunch of random
edgy words and concepts onto a stun
under some strips of paper
you know they wrote like satan stripper
murder lap dance and then threw it all
into a hat
and drew a handful randomly and made it
into a music video
even the satan shoe that he's putting
out that's gotten a lot of attention
with human blood in the soul
the way it's designed it makes it look
like something that the goth kids in my
high school
made themselves at home we're just
missing the fishnet stockings
it's all just painfully derivative and
boring with that said
this guy is doing this and here's the
one difference
he's doing this after intentionally and
carefully cultivating a
following of young children not
teenagers
okay you want to know how young he
appeared on sesame street
he wrote a children's book he performed
at elementary schools
he even said recently and this is his
quote
that children are his core audience so
while the satanist stuff isn't new or
interesting
he is perhaps blazing a new trail by
specifically marketing this
to young children like five years old
his own core audience he says now that
doesn't make him a rebel
or a genius uh just a predator
you know he's a disgusting dirtbag
predator who shouldn't be allowed within
50 yards of a school ever again
and i'd say that even without this song
because his music is so stupid
that i'm afraid it might have an effect
on children that's very similar to the
kind of
effect that repeat head trauma from
football might have on them
his music generally and this in
particular is is stupid desperate
cliched nihilistic
semi-coherent sludge with no value
whatsoever and everyone who listens to
it is lessened by it and dumber for it
and may god have mercy on your soul and
that's just a long way of saying that i
don't really care for it personally